tous donc mes chers collègues nous avons
le plaisir d'accueillir aujourd'hui
madame Marlène Schiappa secrétaire
d'État auprès de la première ministre
chargée de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et de la vie associative entre
nous à tous je lui souhaite la bienvenue
dans notre commission pour des raisons
de calendrier nous n'avions pas eu
encore l'occasion de vous entendre
depuis le début de cette législature il
y a maintenant un an et la vie
associative les associations nous le
constatons tous chaque semaine dans nos
circonscriptions sont un piliers majeur
du tissu social et de la vie économique
de notre nation quelques chiffres
suffisent à en prendre la mesure
1,5 millions d'associations 21 millions
d'adhérents 13 millions de bénévoles 1,8
millions de salariés les enjeux les
problématiques de la vie associative
sont nombreux et la table ronde qui a eu
lieu en mars avec des représentants du
mouvement associatif de France Bénévolat
et du cnavjette knobjet nous a permis de
mieux les appréhender donc je me réjouis
de cette rencontre avec vous Madame la
Ministre qui nous permettra approfondir
notre réflexion et avant de donner la
parole au Commissaire je souhaiterais
moi vous poser quelques questions à
titrelinaire des chiffres clés de la vie
associative en 2023 ont confirmé la
diminution du bénévolat phénomène
enclenché au début des années 2010 et
qui concerne toutes les générations le
nombre de bénévoles est passé de 15
millions en 2021 à 13 millions début
2023 cette crise du bénévolat se
manifeste aussi par une diminution des
dons effectués aux associations et si le
reparte à la hausse depuis 2019 le
nombre de foyers fiscaux ayant déclaré
au moins un don et passer de 5,5
millions en 2013 à 4,8 millions en 2021
et ces évolutions fragilisent de
nombreuses associations comment
percevez-vous la crise du bénévolat et
comment entendez-vous y répondre
plusieurs personnes ont proposé de
revaloriser la dotation du fond de
développement de la vie associative et
je pense notamment à notre collègue
Claudia Rouault qui a proposé dans son
avis budgétaire de porter les crédits du
fdva à 100 millions d'euros donc je
voulais savoir ce que vous pensiez de
cette proposition et enfin
pourrions-nous faire un point d'étape
sur des tables des Assises de la
simplification associative lancée en
début d'année
nombreuses sont les associations qui
attendent un véritable choc de
simplification qui leur permettrait de
dégager davantage de temps pour
l'exercice de leur mission et vous aviez
notamment évoqué la création d'un
guichet unique de l'État pour les
demandes de subvention donc je voulais
savoir si ce projet était toujours à
l'ordre du jour donc voilà les quelques
questions que je souhaitais vous poser
madame la ministre mais je vais vous
donner la parole pour les propos
liminaires
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je suis très
heureuse d'avoir d'être devant vous cet
après-midi pour échanger autour du volet
vie associative de mon ministère c'est
vrai que nous avons en France une
association créée toutes les 7 minutes
ce qui était énorme en Français sur 3
qui est bénévole 20 millions de
Françaises et de Français qui s'engagent
à défendre des causes qui leur tiennent
à cœur et donc c'est certainement pas
des parlementaires que je vais apprendre
à quel point les associations jouent un
rôle irremplaçable dans l'apprentissage
de la vie démocratique par leur culture
de dialogue et de compromis aussi elles
sont un peu une école de la citoyenneté
et après un an en fonction je voudrais
revenir sur ce qui a été notre action
dans ce secrétariat d'État et les
conclusions de la consultation lancée en
décembre 2022 des Assises de la
simplification administrative des
associations alors d'abord peut-être
rappelé que beaucoup de choses ont été
faites au cours de cette année notamment
dans la formation des bénévoles mais
aussi dans la reconnaissance de leur
engagement c'est une demande que
beaucoup d'entre vous avaient porté pour
cela j'ai engagé à le 17 octobre dernier
à Alençon le Tour de France du chocolat
en association avec les élus locaux
l'opération a consisté d'une part à
organiser des ateliers d'idéation pour
recueillir la parole des bénévoles sur
leur bonne pratique mais aussi un peu
sur les irritants des quotidiens et sur
les freins au développement de ces
associations l'idée c'est de construire
des solutions vraiment concrètes
ensemble pour lever ces freins avec la
question de l'engagement exemplaire des
entre guillemets petites mains
associative au service de l'intérêt
collectif en procédant à des remises de
médailles qui sont des médailles d'un
genre nouveau puisqu'elles vise à
récompenser des bénévoles et non pas des
dirigeants associatifs comme on peut le
faire habituellement avec des heures du
mérite ou des médailles Jeunesse et
Sport dès le début du quinquennat nous
avons aussi souhaité avec ma collègue
Carole Grandjean dans le cadre du projet
de loi relatif au marché du travail
porter une attention vraiment
particulière au bénévoles dans le cadre
de la réforme de la VAE je vous rappelle
et beaucoup d'entre vous pris la parole
sur ce sujet le parcours du combattant
que représentait la VAE la forte des
perditions avant la réforme alors que
vous le savez quand on se mobilise pour
l'intérêt général on acquiert des
compétences qui sont inestimables et
donc la VL constitue aussi une
opportunité importante pour transformer
son engagement en certification ou en
diplôme et donc nous avons ensemble
souhaité la rendre plus accessible mais
aussi plus lisible et donc je vous
annonce que nous allons présenter dans
les jours à venir la plateforme dédiée à
la VAE bénévole pour mieux accompagner
les bénévoles qui sont désireux de
transformer leur expérience en diplôme
l'objectif c'est que parmi les 100 000
VAE annuels un tiers environ proviennent
du secteur associatif directement et
c'est donc dans cette idée de formation
tout au long de la vie que le comte
d'engagement citoyen permettant de
transformer son engagement associatif en
crédit sur son CPF a été renforcé nous
l'avons par exemple vous le savez ouvert
pour les sapeurs-pompiers volontaires
avec le ministère de l'Intérieur nous
avons voulu aussi une dame la présidente
pour suivre les forces pour le fdvia et
plus particulièrement sur le volet
formation alors si vous me permettez une
insiste je veux juste ici adresser mes
remerciements officiels à celles et ceux
d'entre vous qui siègent dans les
collèges départementaux du fdja qui
contribuent donc à orienter la stratégie
à deux soutien à la vie associative
départementale vous avez soutenu 80% de
petites associations c'est à dire en
grande majorité uniquement des bénévoles
et permis la formation de 340 000
bénévoles majoritairement dans des
associations qui ne sont pas membres
elles-mêmes de grands réseaux
associatifs donc je crois qu'on peut
dire que l'organisation grâce notamment
la participation des parlementaires
c'est un grand succès avec des bénévoles
très en demande un fort investissement
des réseaux associatifs pour permettre
justement de multiplier les offres de
formation accessible en distancielle et
je suis bien sûr à votre disposition
pour toute remontée de
dysfonctionnements relatif au fdva ou
pour toute à volonté d'évolution du
dispositif et de l'organisation
notamment quand à la participation des
parlementaires je dois dire ici en cela
ma reconnaissance au mouvement
associatif qui déploie une plateforme
recensant les formations disponibles
j'aurais à cœur de les accompagner dans
cette voie la formation elle nous paraît
vraiment primordiale pour reconnaître
l'engagement mais aussi pour fidéliser
ces bénévoles parce qu'elle permet de
simplifier leur quotidien et donc c'est
dans cette voie que nous allons
continuer ces travaux avec les
ministères dédiés en effet lors de
toutes les étapes du Tour de France du
bénévolat que nous avons mené les
acteurs associatifs donc on dit qu'il
souhaitaient absolument se libérer du
temps de leur cœur de métier et passer
moins de temps à remplir des papiers et
des documents et c'est pour ça que
depuis un an nous avons expliqué
pourquoi nous voulions accélérer
l'accompagnement et le soutient la
gouvernance associatif pour lever la
charge administrative parfois superflue
qui porte sur les associations l'idée
c'était de dire libérons du temps
administratif pour qu'ils deviennent
vraiment du temps associatif et c'est
pourquoi nous avons mené cette
consultation au mois de décembre pour
une durée d'un mois nous avons ensuite
grâce à la djeva la direction de la
jeunesse de l'éducation prioritaire et
de la vie associative que je salue
analyser les résultats pendant environ
un mois je veux aussi devant vous
remercier devant la représentation
nationale remercier l'ensemble des têtes
de réseau et des associations qui ont
pris part à cette consultation parce que
sans vous dire que nous avons eu 15000
remontées ce n'est pas anodin 15000
remontées quand on s'adresse à un public
associatif donc ça veut dire que chacun
c'est emparé de cette possibilité de
modifier et d'améliorer les dispositifs
l'expertise la précision l'inventivité
aussi à des résultats étaient très
précieuses je vais avoir un mot aussi
pour les parlementaires qui ont
contribué à ce travail en auditionnant
les acteurs et on organisant des temps
de travail dans leurs écosystèmes et et
dans leur circonscription alors comment
on sort ensuite de ces assises de la
simplification et bien elle répond à un
besoin concret nous l'avons classé en
quatre familles de mesures
simplification reconnaissance engagement
et accompagnement et ensuite et bien
cela se subdivise dans des solutions qui
sont de l'ordre de l'outil de la
circulaire du réglementaire du
budgétaire ou du législatif quelques
exemples peut-être sur la simplification
à partager avec vous pour qu'on sache de
quoi on parle le premier constat que
nous avons fait au quotidien c'est que
pour de nombreuses démarches il y a donc
trop de renseignements trop difficiles
et compliqués à trouver donc notre
volonté c'est d'accompagner la montée en
puissance du dispositif existant qui
s'appelle mon comptable que vous
connaissez de le rendre plus opérant en
facilitant l'interface en donnant aussi
accès à des informations sur
l'accompagnement sur les évolutions
législatives ou bien en répertoriant les
différents dispositifs d'aide auxquels
peuvent prétendre les associations pour
que tout le monde ait le même niveau
d'information l'idée en gros c'est d'en
faire un genre de guichet unique de la
vie associative basée sur la logique qui
a été développée par ailleurs du dites
le nous une fois dans le même temps nous
travaillons pour arriver à simplifier
les formulaires et notamment produire un
document unique de demande de soutien
pour les associations à ce titre je veux
dire que la plurie annualité avec des
CPE doit à notre sens pouvoir devenir la
règle avec des critères d'évaluation
précis tout au long de la vie du projet
puisque les associations et les
bénévoles nous sont revenus à de
multiples reprises pour partager avec
nous le manque de visibilité qui était
le leur en suspendu à des décisions
ponctuelles ou annuelles donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut changer notre manière de
faire notre manière de voir les choses
bâtir vraiment une relation de confiance
avec le secteur associatif dans les
territoires pour encourager la conduite
de projets de plus grande ampleur et
pouvoir vraiment permettre le soutien
donc une liberté associative donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle il nous faut
favoriser des alliances territoriales au
service de cet intérêt général les
acteurs n'étant pas régis par le même
régime juridique doit pouvoir par
exemple s'associer et conduire ensemble
des projets au service d'un bassin de
vie pour cela je pense que nous devons
réfléchir au cadre légal adéquat pour
les développer en associant acteur
associatifs privés publics collectivités
et en créant des ponts entre l'ensemble
de ces acteurs promouvoir l'engagement
c'est aussi faciliter l'équilibre vie
professionnelle vie associative et c'est
pourquoi en ce sens nous sommes en train
de travailler avec mon collègue
Stanislas Guérini pour clarifier le
droit existant sur le mécénat de
compétences nous l'avons développé
récemment il a été en interministériel
soutenu par madame la Première ministre
pour l'ensemble du secteur de la
fonction publique et nous devons
maintenant clarifier ce droit existant
qui empêche le tissu des TPE d'y
recourir sur ce second point nous sommes
montera d'avancer en interministériel
avec nos collègues mais nous avons
besoin aussi d'accroître la notoriété de
l'existant comme le congé d'engagement
qui est encore trop peu utilisé la vie
professionnelle je pense qu'elle doit
plus être un frein à la vie associative
elle doit pouvoir se compléter et
s'enrichir l'une l'autre en se
comprenant et en dégageant du temps
l'une pour l'autre enfin sur le volet
accompagnement j'ai évoqué les travaux
en cours sur le dispositif compte à Sao
qui est un dispositif important en
complément je vous dire que plusieurs
actions sont à l'oeuvre pour assurer un
soutien de proximité et adapter aux
réalités des besoins des associations le
dispositif guidation il est très
apprécié par l'ensemble des acteurs du
bénévolat nous l'avons passé de 3 à 10
régions pour faire en sorte que on
puisse dans le plus grand nombre de
territoires possibles s'y reposer à
nouveau je remercie le mouvement
associatif d'accélérer ce déploiement
dans chaque département cette
coopération les acteurs de terrain je
crois qu'elle est vraiment essentielle
on en mesure les effets concrets dans
nos rendez-vous chaque jour le
déploiement total sur l'ensemble du
territoire pourra se faire à l'horizon
2025 et je veux poursuivre également la
démarche partenariale entre guidasso et
les maisons françaises nous avons pu
ensemble observer des disparités dans
l'inclusion des Français services dans
l'accompagnement des associations mais
leur maillage territorial nous semble
être une bonne première porte d'entrée
pour orienter ensuite vers des secteurs
dit plus classique de l'accompagnement
donc c'est ce que nous allons tâcher de
faire
je veux enfin préciser pour vous
répondre madame la Présidente que la
question du fdva est une question en
discussion ça montre un des chants avec
mon collègue Gabriel Attal pour pour
l'année prochaine mais nous soutenons
bien sûr l'augmentation des moyens
possibles pour le fdva et notamment ce
que je veux rappeler ici qui me semble
important c'est que les entreprises
peuvent alimenter le FDR c'est une
particularité de ce mode de
fonctionnement que vous connaissez très
bien je pense qu'il nous faut continuer
à les solliciter et ne pas hésiter à le
faire ces efforts je crois que nous
devons les poursuivre ensemble tant sur
le secteur associatif qui apporte
souvent des réponses dans les
territoires que sur les besoins
collectifs qui émergent je veux dire que
partout nous avons sur le territoire des
citoyens qui s'organisent pour créer des
crèches des services au plus vulnérables
ou des lieux collectifs qui permettent
l'accès à la culture ou au sport
l'associatif je veux enfin dire en
conclusion que ce n'est pas que du
bénévolat c'est aussi un modèle
économique qui gère différemment ses
profits qui associe différemment ses
parties prenantes autour gouvernance qui
est pleinement démocratique et donc nous
sommes mobilisés ensemble pour
travailler sur cette question et je veux
bien sûr souligner le travail de
Monsieur le Député Quentin bataillon
pour tâcher de traduire ensemble dans la
loi la possibilité de travailler sur
cette simplification administrative des
associations que nous appelons tous
ensemble de nos vœux et dire je suis à
vos côtés aux côtés des acteurs
incontournables du lien social de la
solidarité et de la démocratie au
quotidien qui rayonne dans les
territoires je vous remercie je suis à
votre entière disposition pour répondre
à vos questions vos interpellations
merci Madame la Ministre donc maintenant
nous allons passer aux orateurs de
groupe et nous allons commencer par le
groupe Renaissance avec Quentin
bataillon
merci beaucoup à la présidente
d'avoir inscrit la vie associative sur
la feuille de route du gouvernement et
ce dès le début du quinquennat c'est
effectivement à noter cet apprécié sur
le terrain que vous l'avez dit la grande
consultation que vous venez de nous
présenter à travers l'ensemble de ces
résultats permet une connexion directe à
la réalité du terrain et ceci en
complémentarité parfaite avec le travail
réalisé par différentes têtes de réseau
que vous avez également cité en effet
député de la gloire je sais ce que nous
devons milliers de bénévoles qui font
vivre nos associations à Saint-Etienne
ça génère Villars a pris en jarret
Roche-la-Molière ou encore à
Saint-Jean-Bonnefonds elles sont près
d'un millier à faire vivre le sport la
culture la citoyenneté la solidarité
personne n'y l'État ni les collectivités
territoire et encore moins des
entreprises privées ne peuvent les
suppléer elle seule peut permettre au
plus grand nombre de nos concitoyens
d'accéder à des biens à des
connaissances ou à des activités à la
fois en commun il y a des coûts réduits
de s'élever et de déjouer des
déterminismes sociaux elle permet de se
lier social à la fois en confiance en
proximité dans notre société à temps
besoin depuis plusieurs mois les trois
groupes parlementaires de la majorité
comme vous l'avez dit même la ministre
ont entamé à vos côtés également des
travaux d'audition de réflexion afin
d'accompagner aussi d'un point de vue
législatif ce que vous venez de nous
présenter ceci viendront compléter les
différents points que vous avez soulevés
afin de favoriser l'engagement
associatif et simplifier la vie de nos
associations permettront notamment une
meilleure alliance entre la vie
professionnelle et l'engagement
associatif notamment à travers la
formation ou les congés d'engagement
d'ailleurs chers collègues notons quel
que soit l'avis de chacun de se réforme
des retraites que pour la première fois
nous avons inscrit dans la dernière
forme des retraites une obligation pour
l'État d'avoir une réflexion sur la
valorisation de l'engagement associatif
dans le calcul des droits à la retraite
nous aurons également en plus de la
boutique très forte en matière de
mécénat fiscale une politique en matière
de messena de compétence c'est-à-dire la
mise à disposition d'employés pour nous
associations des éléments fiscaux forts
et je n'ai pas peur de le citer nous
travaillerons fortement que le
gouvernement afin d'obtenir la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation pour
les associations qui est un prélèvement
injuste pour un certain nombre d'entre
elles vous l'avez compris madame
ministre nous serons à vos côtés pour
amplifier complémenter l'ensemble de
votre travaux et nous vous remercions
pour votre présentation d'aujourd'hui
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
rassemblement national Julien Oudoul
merci madame la présidente madame la
secrétaire d'État chers collègues en
2020 lorsque vous étiez ministre de la
Citoyenneté vous avez mis en place une
charte de la laïcité obligatoire pour
toutes les associations recevant des
financements publics sans jamais
vraiment nommer l'entrisme islamiste qui
gangrène le milieu associatif dans
certains quartiers vous aviez même
étendu cette charte aux associations
dans le domaine du sport et de la
politique de la ville dans la loi
séparatisme mais trois ans après l'heure
est au bilan et visiblement ce bilan
n'est pas reluisant il y a quelques
jours je pense que madame vous avait été
choqué comme nous par la décision du
rapporteur public du Conseil d'État
concernant les revendications de
militantes islamistes pour le port du
hijab dans les compétitions sportives
c'est un fait les structures sportives
associatives ou culturelles qui font la
promotion du hijab et qui profite d'un
flou juridique se multiplie dans notre
pays et sont largement autre passés
cette Charte de la laïcité qui n'est en
rien un rempart plus largement
l'augmentation du nombre d'associations
culturelles de type communautaire est à
déplorer des clubs de sport qui
deviennent des officines palestiniennes
des drapeaux communautaires qui se
multiplient des cours qui sont réservés
aux femmes tout cela existe
malheureusement et visiblement la charte
de laïcité a du mal aller contrecarrer
en 2020 vous pointiez à juste titre la
ségrégation entre filles garçons mais
que dire aussi de l'antisémitisme dans
certaines structures associatives que
dire du racisme et de tous les racismes
y compris du racisme antiblant face à
ces dérives alarmantes il est clair
qu'une charte ne fera reculer en rien
l'entrisme islamiste dès lors je me
questionne sur la pertinence de la mise
en place de cette de ce dispositif pour
des associations qui sont déjà
marginalisées en rupture avec la
République quel bilan madame la
secrétaire d'État faites-vous quelles
ont été les effets réels et concrets de
cette Charte de la laïcité combien
d'associations étaient dissoutes combien
sont revenus dans le droit chemin
républicain combien de subventions
coupées merci pour vos réponses merci
monsieur le député pour elle est finie
peste Paul Vanier merci madame la
Présidente vous vous présentez devant
nous dans un contexte marqué par votre
récente audition devant la commission
d'enquête fond Marianne du Sénat à son
issue le rapporteur Husson déclarait à
votre sujet je le cite elle ne m'a pas
convaincu elle s'est mise en porte à
faux elle n'a cessé de se défausser
notre rapport conclura qu'elle ne dit
pas la vérité la justice fera son
travail derrière en dépit de ce contexte
et en l'absence de crédit du crédit que
nous pouvons aujourd'hui accorder à
votre parole vous êtes aujourd'hui face
à nous contacter je vous poserai donc au
prisme de ce qui convient d'appeler
l'affaire Schiappa deux questions
relatives au thème de votre audition la
première concerne le financement des
associations l'affaire Schiappa révèle
une pratique discrétionnaire et opaque à
un favoritisme structurel mis en oeuvre
par votre cabinet dans l'attribution des
subsides du fond Marianne selon
plusieurs enquêtes de presse votre
cabinet a directement participé à la
sélection des bénéficiaires du fond
Marianne et vous êtes vous-même
intervenu pour en écarter une
association SOS Racisme à la lumière de
ces pratiques je souhaiterais connaître
votre conception du mode et des
procédures de financement du monde
associatif ma seconde question porte sur
votre vision de la place et du rôle des
associations dans notre vie démocratique
l'affaire Schiappa révèle une forme
d'instrumentalisation par le pouvoir
macroniste de certaines associations à
des fins politiques ainsi l'association
reconstruire le commun
a-t-elle manifestement été créé et
financé pour mener une campagne de
dénigrement contre vos adversaires
politiques notamment contre Anne Hidalgo
et Jean-Luc Mélenchon en pleine période
électorale cette pratique qui consiste à
financer avec de l'argent public des
officines de propagande macronistes
rappelle le syndicat fictif à venir
lycéen largement arrosé par Jean-Michel
Blanquer dont deux des dirigeants seront
présentés demain devant la justice à la
lumière de laisser révélations
pouvez-vous nous indiquer comment la
secrétaire d'État à la vie associative
que vous êtes devenu qu'on soit-elle le
rôle et la place des associations dans
notre vie démocratique maintenant la
secrétaire d'État je vous ai pratiquant
la diversion et la confusion par
omission j'espère que vous apporterez
des réponses claires et précises à mes
questions merci monsieur le député donc
je vais quand même apporter une quelques
précisions le Sénat effectue des travaux
ce ne sont pas ceux de l'assemblée il
n'a pas rendu ses conclusions donc en
fait les propos que vous tenez en disant
que la ministre la parole n'est pas
crédible en vous basant quand même sur
les les propos de du Sénat je trouve
sont mal venus dans notre enceinte
faisons-nous notre opinion ici par
rapport
moi je peux quand même aussi vous vous
faire part des propos je pense qu'on ne
n'allons pas interférer dans les travaux
du Sénat et là nous sommes là en
audition sur la vie associative donc on
va laisser la ministre répondre ensuite
Maxime minot pour les républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre le milieu associatif français
et en particulier le milieu sportif dans
certains territoires spécifiques et de
plus en plus souvent la cible de
l'intégrisme religieux principalement
l'islamisme intégriste
sur 2450 lieu de culte musulmans les
renseignements intérieurs des nombres
une centaine de mosquée dites salafist
mais leurs activités sont difficil
difficilement quantifiables tant elles
se développent sur internet et les
réseaux sociaux en France les adeptes
sont plutôt des jeunes hommes âgés de 18
à 30 ans mais aussi des Quincas et des
sexagénaires à l'encrage de cette
mouvance dans notre pays datant des
années 1990 outre internet ces
prédicateurs utilisent leurs
associations sportives pour capter un
auditoire jeune notamment via les salles
de sport lieu de rassemblement d'une
certaine jeunesse et transmettent leur
lieu de idéologie pardon conduisant
souvent à une radicalisation de ces
jeunes le milieu sportif est
régulièrement pointé du doigt par des
rapports ou des notes des renseignements
généraux alertant sur les dérives
communautaires ou la radicalisation dans
le milieu association associatif
depuis longtemps les républicains se
font le relais des alertes de nombreux
éducateurs sportifs témoins dans leurs
associations ou celle de sport des
dérives communautaires notamment des
prières dans les vestiaires ou des
pressions sur les tenues vestimentaires
des jeunes femmes licenciés ma question
est donc simple madame la ministre que
comptez-vous faire pour préserver nos
associations en général et sportives en
particulier de ce prosélytisme religieux
sur lequel nous alertons votre
gouvernement depuis bien trop longtemps
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député pour les démocrates Sophie met
elle était en train de faire la DG donc
on va la laisser arriver à moins que
Estelle
donc pour les socialistes apparentés
Isabelle je vais quand même prendre la
question et si Sophie revient à temps et
ben elle rentre d'accord autrement je la
faisait passer à la fin c'est comme
comme tu veux voilà donc pour les
socialistes à partentiaque et loi Achi
si madame la présidente madame la
ministre le monde associatif est en
crise une crise profonde alimentée
depuis plusieurs années par un sentiment
de défiance croissant envers les
associations et leurs bénévoles en tant
que co-président du groupe d'études sur
l'éducation populaire j'ai pu mesurer
tout au long de mes auditions
l'inquiétude des acteurs associatifs il
dénonce un flou autour de leur avenir en
l'absence de cap du gouvernement qui
préfère se concentrer sur un s&u coûteux
et sans objectif clair depuis 2017 les
réformes menées par les gouvernements
successifs n'ont fait que fragiliser les
associations sur le plan financier
suffisant criante du fond de
développement de la vie associative puis
la suppression en 2018 de la réserve
parlementaire n'a eu pour effet que
déroder des finances déjà exemples
depuis la crise sanitaire
justement au plus fort de la crise alors
que les associations demandaient des
moyens supplémentaires et des démarches
administratives facilité le gouvernement
préféré les contraindre davantage au
moyen du contrat d'engagement République
pire encore ce contrat a fait entrer
dans le monde associatif une aire de
suspicion généralisée il est aujourd'hui
largement dévoyé ouvrant la porte à la
mise en danger sans précédent de la
liberté d'associations aussi deux ans
après l'entrée en vigueur de son contrat
d'engagement républicain au combien
décrié quel bilan pouvez-vous en dresser
comptez-vous madame la ministre
réévaluer ce contrat au vu de la crise
de confiance majeure qu'il alimente
depuis près de deux ans
comment comptez-vous dans ce contexte
agir pour redynamiser le monde
associatif et rétablir un lien de
confiance brisé nous notre pays est fort
de son tissu associatif dense qui
favorise l'émancipation et le vivre
ensemble son rôle est essentiel face au
l'offensive de repli de l'extrême droite
madame la ministre c'est de votre
responsabilité de soutenir le tissu
associatif je vous remercie merci madame
la députée pour horizon et la parenté
Béatrice Bellamy
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je vous remercie de prendre
part aux travaux de notre commission
aujourd'hui cela nous permet d'aborder
ensemble la vie qui mâille nos
territoires celle qui existe grâce au
millier de bénévoles et qui permet
l'existence d'une véritable identité
pour la collectivité je pense
naturellement à la vie associative
depuis un an madame la ministre comme
d'autres de mes collègues j'ai été
honoré de participer à la gouvernance du
fond de développement pour la vie
associative au niveau du département de
la Vendée durant ces derniers mois nous
nous sommes donc rencontrés à plusieurs
reprises en lien avec les services de la
préfecture cheville indispensable et
dont je salue le remarquable travail
cependant force est de constater madame
la ministre l'identification de deux
points se révélant être des freins ou
déploiement du fdva tout d'abord je
soulèverai la lourdeur lourdeur de la
procédure administrative car la mise en
place d'un dossier son traitement avec
les moyens humains que cela engendre
sont parfois voire souvent de vins
efforts
si les associations les plus importantes
comme les comités départementaux sont en
fait et disposent de davantage de moyens
et donc de temps pour présenter un
dossier ce n'est pas toujours le cas des
petites associations cela me permet de
soulever ce second point celui du
périmètre d'action du fdva c'est même
associations qui pourtant donnent une
arme à nos cérémonies à nos compétitions
sportives n'ont pas les mêmes moyens et
ne bénéficient pas du véritable
ruissellement au sein du territoire
normalement attendu
je souhaiterais donc vous exprimer ma
sincère regret celui que ces
associations ne soient pas davantage
soutenues dans leur vie quotidienne avec
des achats de drapeaux de matériel par
exemple aussi madame la ministre
pourriez-vous nous expliquer quelle
mesure vous envisagez de soutenir pour
simplifier ces démarches hormis des
réunions publiques mais aussi et surtout
comment se font je pourrais bénéficier à
en plus grand nombre d'associations
enfin le FDA est souvent méconnu je m'en
aperçois lors de mes déplacements
comment pourrions-nous mettre en avant
ce bel outil pour que les élus et
bénévoles et le réflexe de le solliciter
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
pour les démocrates Sophie mettent
merci madame le Président Madame la
Ministre
les députés du groupe némote vous
rejoignent dans votre volonté de
simplification de la vie associative il
faut permettre aux 22 millions de
Françaises et de Français qui donnent du
temps pour les autres ou pour contribuer
à une cause d'être enfin reconnu et
remercier pour leur bénévolat ce ne sont
pas moins d'un virgule 3 millions
d'associations qui sont aujourd'hui
actives sur notre territoire et qui et
qui continue à faire vivre de faire
vivre le lien social détériorer lors de
la pandémie de covid-19 des voies du
milieu associatif se sont faites
entendre dans la vie du CESU publié en
juin de l'année dernière il a été
souligné que le taux d'évolution globale
des subventions publiques étaient en
diminution de presque 10% sur la période
2011-2017 alors que le même indicateur
sur la même période s'agissant des
commandes publiques était de plus oui
pour cent ces recours croissent ce
recours croissant au dispositif de la
commande publique pénalise les petites
et moyennes associations très ancrées
dans le tissu local avec une présence
importante voire quasi exclusive de
bénévoles malheureusement la tendance
est alors la concentration des grandes
associations de moins en moins
nombreuses mais de plus grande taille
qui captent l'essentiel des financements
publics alors que de l'autre côté se
développe un secteur de
micro-associations madame la minisette à
propos de la répartition équitable des
financements publics au sein du milieu
associatif que je souhaite recueillir
vos convictions comment l'inclure dans
un futur projet de loi ce sont ces
petites associations qui font vivre nos
villages nos zones rurales il faut les
épauler pour qu'ils puissent mener les
projets pour lesquels ils se sont
engagés et non les réduire à des
chasseurs de fonds de trésorerie je vous
remercie merci madame la députée
pour les écologistes nups jean-claudeau
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre ces dernières semaines
l'actualité associative a été bousculée
par une affaire et les regrettables
comme l'a écrit une journaliste de
challenge que le responsable politique
n'est toujours pas compris à quel point
le nom respect des règles la tromperie
la manipulation l'absence de
transparence sont des vis qui ruinent la
démocratie je referme les guillemets
constatent que ces dernières années le
monde associatif a été grandement
bousculé je crois que l'on peut même
objectivement dire qu'il a souffert et
qu'il souffre encore je voudrais vous
parler spécifiquement de l'érosion du
bénévolat cette érosion n'est pas
nouvelle elle est à l'oeuvre depuis le
début des années 2010 mais elle s'est
aggravée avec la pandémie puisque la
part de la population impliquée dans une
association est passée de 24% en 2019 à
20% en 2022 les plus impactés par le
recul de l'engagement bénévole ce sont
les 35-49 ans et les plus de 65 ans
en effet le retraités sont véritablement
la colonne vertébrale du réseau
associatif français plus d'un bénévole
sur trois est à la retraite je suis
inquiet des effets à venir de la réforme
des retraites en repoussant l'âge de
départ à 64 ans il est clair que
l'afflux des nouveaux retraités sera
désormais moins moindre là d'une
carrière professionnelle longue et
usante il est fort probable que nombre
d'entre eux renoncent à s'engager une
fois arrivé à la retraite plusieurs
responsables d'associations vous ont
d'ailleurs déjà interpellé sur cette
question les différences sont
générationnelles mais aussi
territoriales si le développement du
tissu associatif local et primordial
pour tout territoire il est peut-être
encore plus dans les territoires
éloignés des services publics puisque ce
réseau associatif permet de pallier le
désengagement de l'État je suis élu
d'une circonscription rurale et
j'observe tous les jours cette érosion
du bénévolat qui est encore plus criante
dans nos campagnes
je voudrais cependant souligner que
l'engagement au sein d'association
environnementale qui lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique résiste
globalement à cette érosion des
bénévoles surtout ces associations
recrutent particulièrement chez les
15-35 ans après ce point positif ma
question est donc la suivante face à
l'érosion des bénévoles dans le monde
associatif qui est à l'oeuvre et qui
risque d'augmenter encore
quelles sont les propositions
incitatives au bénévolat autre que la
contrainte comme vous tentez de
l'imposer avec le RSA et le SNU par
exemple
merci monsieur le député pour GDR nups
Soumia Bourgoin merci Madame la madame
la présidente madame la ministre il y a
5 mois vous lancez une consultation
auprès des associations pour identifier
les mesures à prendre afin de leur
faciliter la vie à administrativement
parmi leurs demandes se trouve la
création d'un guichet unique afin de
centraliser les demandes de subvention
l'accès à des services numériques
simples et intuitif et l'accès à un
accompagnement renforcé dans la
gouvernance associative et la formation
des bénévoles nous savons l'importance
des associations dans notre pays qui par
l'engagement des bénévoles des salariés
dont par son mariage territorial et les
missions qu'elle remplisse constituée un
élément essentiel dans la vie de nos
concitoyens et concitoyens pouvez-vous
madame la ministre préciser les mesures
que vous prendrez répondant concrètement
aux demandes les associations en
particulier en termes d'accompagnement
administratif et de formation des
bénévoles non second point concernera le
bilan du contrat d'engagement
républicain dispositif introduit sous le
précédent mandat lors de la loi sur les
principes de la République dispositif
instaurant une sorte de présomption de
culpabilité pour les associations sommet
de signer un contrat pour toucher des
subventions le bilan qu'on tire le
mouvement associatif est plus que mitigé
des abus ont été constatés comme dans le
cas d'alternatiba Poitiers qui a vu la
subvention de la Ville menacée
un atelier sur la désobéissance civile
cela s'inscrit dans le contexte que nous
connaissons avec la dissolution du
soulèvement de la terre quoi que nous
pensions que des modes d'action et selon
notre préoccupant pour la liberté
associative nous vous demandons
d'aborder ce contrat de revenir à la
charte d'engagement réciproque pour un
partenariat renouvelé entre toutes les
parties prenantes mais sur des bases
beaucoup plus respectueuses des apports
du mouvement associatif dans notre pays
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
pour le groupe Stéphane Lenormand
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre moi je voudrais revenir sur
trois points le premier concernant la
suppression de la réserve parlementaire
on l'a évoqué il y a dispositif qui a
été mise en place qui pour moi n'est pas
forcément ni plus vertueux ni plus
limpide et certainement moins
intéressant pour les associations donc
au vu de votre regard et de votre
expertise j'aimerais savoir quel est
votre opinion sur les effets de cette
suppression auprès des associations des
diverses associations qui qui ont
bénéficié auparavant et qui pour moi
aussi était un lien entre l'élu et sa
circonscription et la vie associative le
deuxième toujours dans cette démarche
sur la réserve parlementaire vous savez
qu'il y a un texte qui a été déposé par
à peu près 120 députés je m'avance pas
trop sans dire qu'il est presque
transpartisan j'aimerais avoir votre
position madame la ministre si vous
allez favoriser l'inscription de cette
PPL dans l'ordre du jour de l'Assemblée
nationale enfin dernier point je
voudrais insister aussi j'aimerais avoir
votre avis sur les outre-mer le tissu
associatif est important naturellement
dans l'Hexagone comme en outre-mer mais
particulièrement en outre-mer où nous
avons des particularités des
spécificités si je prends le cas de la
Polynésie qui un territoire grand comme
l'Europe et si je prends mon territoire
qui est un confettis dans l'océan
Atlantique souvent la vie des
associations les échanges sont bloqués
par les difficultés au déplacement par
exemple qui fait que on est un peu
obligé de rester sur place donc
j'aimerais savoir dans votre ministère
comment vous appréhendez le fait
outre-mer merci merci monsieur le député
mesdames la ministre vous avez la parole
pour répondre à ces premières questions
merci madame la Présidente je vais
tâcher de regrouper peut-être certaines
réponses quand les sujets se recoupent
si vous me le permettez bien sûr mais je
suis à disposition pour apporter telle
ou tel précision d'abord monsieur le
député Quentin bataillon je vous
remercie pour vos propos et pour votre
engagement auprès du secteur associatif
c'est que vous avez pris pleine part à
cette question des Assises de la
simplification
administrative et dans le cadre de ces
assises on a pu ensemble débusquer un
certain nombre de dispositifs de lois
assez ubuesque qu'il contient
d'actualiser pour permettre aux
associations de pleinement prendre toute
leur part dans la simplification qui
soit vraiment efficace et qui viennent
leur libérer du temps associatif et leur
dégager du temps administratif et je
crois profondément tout comme vous
monsieur le député que ça répondra aussi
quelque part à la question de
l'attractivité des activités bénévoles
dans la mesure où nous voyons des
bénévoles qui se découragent parce
qu'ils viennent pour par exemple faire
des maraudes ou être solidaire ou
soutenir ou apporter une activité faire
de l'animation et puis qui se retrouvent
en fait à remplir des documents dans un
bureau à être un peu isolé alors qu'ils
étaient venus chercher du lien social
donc je suis très convaincu que ce
projet que vous portez cette proposition
de loi pour simplifier davantage la vie
associative va être extrêmement efficace
en tout cas nous serons avec vous pour
la soutenir dans l'ensemble de ses
composantes y compris dans celles que
vous avez évoqué Ré sur sur la taxe
d'habitation et la question associatif
monsieur le député Julien Hauteville
alors je vais répondre à ce que vous
dire mais vous avez dit que je n'avais
pas nommé l'islamisme je crois qu'on me
reproche plutôt le contraire depuis
quelques années donc il me semble que
j'ai toujours nommé au contraire la
menace islamiste et l'islamisme radical
y compris en prenant des positions très
fortes contre certaines organisations
positions que probablement Juppé hier à
un moment dans mon engagement politique
mais c'est un autre sujet et je veux
dire que je n'ai jamais cru que cette
Charte de la laïcité était suffisante en
elle-même d'ailleurs quand je l'avais
lancé moi-même dans des précédentes
fonctions quand j'étais chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
j'avais dit moi-même c'était une charte
que c'était un document qui n'avait pas
valeur légale et c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi nous avons ensuite dans la loi
il est parlementaire autour de la table
ont débattu et certains ont voté créé le
contrat d'engagement républicain qui lui
a valeur législatives permet de dire
qu'une finance que des organisations qui
sont respectueuses des valeurs de la
République et qu'on peut également se
faire rembourser des subventions qui
auraient été distrib j'ai souvent donné
l'exemple de dire que le maire de
Grenoble qui a financé le CCIF pendant
un temps donné et bien s'il y a vu le
contrat d'engagement républicain à ce
moment-là qu'il avait dit que deux
bonnes foi il ne savaient pas que le
CCIF était une organisation telle
qu'elle est et bien il aurait pu
demander le remboursement de ces
subventions en tout cas c'est ce que
nous avons fait rentrer dans la loi avec
le contrat d'engagement républicain nous
avons eu des dissolutions nombreuses le
ministre de l'Intérieur géraldamin
s'exprimé il y a eu 15 dissolutions
depuis 2021 notamment donc le CCIF parmi
d'autres organisations qui ne
respectaient pas les principes de la
République ou qui représentaient une
menace de troubles à l'ordre public donc
ce contrat d'engagement républicain il
vient suppléer et remplacer finalement
l'ensemble des chars de la laïcité qui
pouvaient exister il y en a vu notamment
dans la région Île-de-France on a vu
dans la ville de Montpellier certains
élus qui avaient voulu prendre des
initiatives sur ces sujets aujourd'hui
le contrat d'engagement républicain et
bien il vient avoir cette valeur
législative et donner justement et bien
une capacité de pouvoir récupérer les
financements aussi davantage euh c'est
d'aventure pardon on s'apercevait qu'il
n'était pas en fait respectueux des
principes de la République
Monsieur le Député
Maximino je vais vous dire que sur la
question de la laïcité également dans et
de la place des femmes dans le sport
c'est une question extrêmement
importante extrêmement préoccupante le
gouvernement s'en occupe ma collègue
Amélie ou desa Castéra qui est ministre
des Sports a pris plusieurs décisions et
fait des déclarations en ce sens pour
rappeler à quel point ils ne pouvait pas
y avoir de discrimination ou de
communautarisme dans la vie sportive le
ministre de l'intérieur c'est d'ailleurs
exprimé encore récemment sur ce sujet et
donc je veux dire que nous menons un
travail avec le ministère des Sports à
cet égard pour faire en sorte justement
de préserver et de protéger cela et le
contrat d'engagement républicain que
j'évoquais plus haut et je le crois en
tout cas une un outil législatif
important pour justement contraindre et
exercer un certain nombre de contrôle le
ministère de l'intérieur par exemple
réalisent des clients qui sont des
contrôles et des organisations au cours
desquelles on passe en Rev un certain
nombre d'organisations justement pour
apporter des réponses à ce que vous sous
leviez madame la député quelle loi assis
je crois que vous avez évoqué aussi la
question du contrat d'engagement
républicain en spécifiant qu'il pouvait
y avoir si j'ai bien retenu vos propos
des problèmes dans l'interprétation du
contrat d'engagement républicain vous
nous demandez si nous entendons le
réviser alors nous n'entendons ni
l'abroger ni le réviser je veux être
très clair là-dessus il a été voté dans
la loi je respectueuse des votes des
parlementaires et donc aujourd'hui c'est
un outil qui est dans la loi et que nous
nous tâchons de faire appliquer
maintenant il peut y avoir effectivement
des mauvaises interprétations et c'est
pourquoi avec ma collègue Sonia baquet
ce qui est chargée de la citoyenneté qui
a aujourd'hui en charge le suivi du
dossier du contrat d'engagement
républicain et bien nous avons édité un
guide en février dernier pour être sûr
que les dispositifs du contrat
d'engagement républicain soit pleinement
compris qui n'entravent pas la liberté
associative il y a eu effectivement
quelques sur-interprétations elles nous
ont été remontées nous avons trouvé des
solutions à chaque fois si vous même
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
vous identifiez des peut-être des
problèmes de compréhension ou
d'interprétation ou de mise en oeuvre de
ce contrat d'engagement républicains de
quel que soit l'endroit d'où ça vient
n'hésitez pas bien sûr à nous les faire
remonter pour qu'on puisse là aussi
prendre les mesures et intervenir pour
faire respecter la loi tant dans le
contrat d'engagement républicain que
bien sûr dans la liberté associative qui
fait partie des dispositions du Contrat
d'Engagement républicain
peut-être sur la question du fdva qui a
été soulevé à plusieurs reprises par
Madame la Députée Bellamy notamment par
Monsieur le Député le Normand également
avec l'angle réserve parlementaire et
par d'autres députés je crois pardon je
n'ai pas tout noté par madame la
Présidente effectivement alors d'abord
je veux dire qu'effectivement comme vous
l'avez souligné vous avez plusieurs à
l'avoir souligné on a trop de petites
associations qui peinent à se porter
candidate au fdva alors qu'en fait elles
en sont la cible principale le FDR
effectivement j'ai été créée à la base
pour ça je veux rappeler quand même que
80% des bénéficiaires du fdva ont moins
de deux salariés et c'est pourquoi on
veut justement se saisir de ces assises
de la simplification pour tendre vers un
formulaire plus lisible et pour
accompagner aussi par voie numérique
avec le guichet du comtesseau et
également en présentiel les équipes de
délégués départementaux à la vie
associative pour que vraiment ça
devienne vraiment accessible le fdva et
qu'on puisse vraiment avancer à cet
égard sur la question du débat entre la
réserve parlementaire et le fdva je veux
dire que la force du FDR moi je crois
qu'elle réside justement dans sa
capacité à répondre aux besoins d'un
territoire en déclinant vraiment
localement des grandes priorités
nationales qui sont fixées par un comité
du monde associatif 340 000 bénévoles
formés 80% de petites associations je le
disais et tel qu'il est conçu il associe
un grand nombre d'entre vous autour du
préfet pour orienter des financements
vers les tissus associatifs on a eu
beaucoup de retours positifs d'ailleurs
je veux le dire de la majorité comme des
oppositions de la campagne avec des va
bien de s'achever néanmoins je veux dire
aussi si vous avez des remontées
particulières des blocages des
associations pas prises en compte ou des
moments dans lesquels les parlementaires
ne sont pas associés comme ils le
devraient théoriquement n'hésitez pas
vraiment à nous en faire part c'est le
sens du courrier que j'ai adressé à la
totalité des parlementaires membres du
collège je remercie d'ailleurs ceux qui
m'ont d'ores et déjà fait part de leurs
observations à cet égard parce que c'est
très précieux pour nous ça nous permet
ensuite de mieux activer le dispositif
sur place je veux dire que ce fdva il
respecte aussi l'indépendance de chaque
organisation à cet égard
sur la question du de l'érosion du
bénévolat monsieur le député ro je veux
dire que c'est vrai vous avez raison on
constate que certains à la faveur du
confinement certains bénévoles sont
partis et ne sont pas revenus ensuite
mais on observe aussi un renouvellement
des générations je veux le dire c'est
extrêmement important les associations
qu'on reçoit tous les jours dans mon
ministère nous disent à quel point il y
a de plus en plus de jeune bénévoles qui
s'engagent et qui s'engage différemment
qui s'engagent peut-être pas en prenant
une carte dans une association et en
donnant un engagement de temps comme
c'était le cas pour nos générations mais
qui s'engagent de manière plus
sporadique parfois mais de manière aussi
avec des actions en tant qu'activisme
vous mentionnez l'engagement écologiste
c'est vrai que dans les mouvements
féministes on voit aussi plus en plus de
jeunes bénévoles c'est ce qu'elle nous
disent en tout cas qui viennent
s'engager donc je pense que moi j'ai pas
je veux pas être pessimiste sur la
question du bénévolat j'ai le sentiment
au contraire qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup
de nos concitoyens qui s'engagent mais
peut-être de nouvelles manières et que
c'est aussi le sens du dialogue qu'on
est en train de mener avec le Tour de
France du bénévolat avec les
associations et avec les bénévoles pour
essayer de comprendre comment on peut
répondre aux besoins de bénévoles des
associations tout en respectant cette
nouvelle manière de s'engager pour ces
nouvelles générations madame la députée
Sophie maid vous avez mentionné à la
question des petites associations vous
avez raison je l'ai rappelé à plusieurs
reprises la question des associations de
de taille modeste elle est fondamentale
pour nous c'est pour ça aussi qu'on veut
aller vraiment au plus près des
territoires qu'on a notamment lancé des
conventions nationales avec les crêtes
les Chambres régionales d'économie
sociale et solidaire dans lesquelles
vous avez de nombreuses associations de
terrain pour vraiment être en lien en
direct avec ces associations et pouvoir
leur apporter des réponses et là aussi
bien sûr on est à votre disposition tant
au niveau du FDV à local qu'au niveau de
l'administration centrale pour pouvoir y
apporter des réponses le plus le plus
clair possible sur la question monsieur
le député le Normand des Outre-mer je
vous dire que c'est effectivement un
sujet qui nous préoccupe et je vous
remercie de bien sûr de de le mentionner
comme vous le faites à chaque fois on
est en train de travailler avec les
différentes parties prenantes et je vous
l'annonce et je vous lance un appel par
la même occasion pour organiser à
l'automne une première convention de
l'économie sociale dans les outre-mer on
est en train avec ESF France à cet égard
et l'idée pour nous c'est de trouver le
bon point d'entrée dans les outre-mer le
bon endroit le bon tempo pour Mobil à la
fois la grande richesse du tissu
associatif de l'économie sociale au sens
là donc y ajouter fondation
coopérative entreprise ESAT etc etc et
de faire en sorte d'une part de les
mettre en valeur d'autre part de l'effet
des Ré et troisièmement devenir les
écouter parce que nous n'ignorons pas
qu'il y a des spécificités dans ces
territoires et qu'on doit pouvoir y
apporter des réponses toutes
particulières
enfin Monsieur le Député Paul vanille
alors je vous remercie pour votre
question tout en mesure et en nuances et
en subtilité
bien sûr
mais bien sûr à la hauteur de votre
grandeur non mais je veux d'abord plus
sérieusement rappeler pardon de le dire
vous vous semblez passionné par cette
affaire mais vous ne semblez pas je me
disais avec tout le respect que j'ai non
pas comme tous les Français d'accord
mais en tout cas vous n'avez pas
manifestement regardé les trois heures
je veux bien répondre à Monsieur le
Député si c'est possible je vous ne
semblez pas avoir regardé mes trois
heures d'audition auprès du Sénat parce
que vous avez posé des questions qui ont
les réponses ont été apportées au cours
de cette audition d'abord je veux
rappeler parce que vous êtes très habile
vous êtes intelligent et subtil et donc
vous avez posé des questions en tenant
des propos qui auraient été différemment
si vous les aviez indiqué à la forme
affirmative mais vous avez mis un point
d'interrogation à la fin que ce ne soit
pas différent mais que ce soit quand
même suffisamment tendancieux pour
qu'une personne qui va écouter votre
capsule que vous manquerez pas de poster
sur les réseaux sociaux se disent oh mon
dieu c'est scandaleux que ce monsieur
est en train de dire qu'est-ce qu'elle a
fait cette Marlène Schiappa mais en fait
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait dans l'audition
au Sénat monsieur le Président de la
commission du Sénat a dit mais vous
n'êtes coupables de rien et d'ailleurs
vous n'êtes même accusé de rien donc moi
je veux bien on peut se poser plein de
questions suis-je une bonne ministre ou
pas je pense que vous avez votre réponse
et vous avez parfaitement le droit de
l'avoir nous sommes en démocratie est-ce
que j'ai bien formulé des appels
d'offres ou pas vous avez parfaitement
le droit d'avoir un point de vue
là-dessus y compris extrêmement négatif
nous sommes en démocratie mais ne faites
pas croire qu'il y a eu des affaires de
détournement de favoritisme qui
tomberaient sous le coup de la loi parce
que ce n'est pas vrai je ne suis
aujourd'hui poursuivi en rien accusé de
rien j'ai répondu de bonne foi au Sénat
dans la limite des informations dont je
me disposer je ne suis pas en mesure de
faire des comptes rendus de réunion
auquel je n'ai pas participé comme vous
le sauriez pas mais il me semble avoir
apporté des réponses je veux notamment
dire que sur l'association reconstruire
le commun que vous avez nommé qui a elle
aussi été auditionnée au Sénat il est
totalement faux pardon monsieur le
député de dire que ce serait une
officine qui aurait fait des vidéos
anti-gauche en fait ce qu'il a été
démontré dans l'audition j'ai envie de
chacun à la regarder parce que ça
intéresse apparemment tout le monde
c'est une audition longue cette
association de reconstruire le commun
elle explique que non seulement elle ne
sait pas créer à ma demande on est là
dans un fantasme complet et il est
démontré qu'elle n'est jamais créée à ma
demande à aucune reprise il est démontré
aussi que cette association elle a
effectivement fait des vidéos contre
madame Hidalgo et contre Monsieur
Mélenchon elle a aussi produit des veaux
des vidéos contre Monsieur Véran contre
Monsieur Darmanin votre madame Schiappa
et même contre Monsieur le Président de
la République donc dit poser la question
savoir si cette association est efficace
ou pas on peut parfaitement se poser la
question mais dire que c'est une
officine lancée par le gouvernement pour
dénigrer ses adversaires non c'est faux
il est démontré que ce n'est pas le cas
et si un jour quelqu'un lance une
officine je pense que personne en sera
une officine contre lui-même en lui
demandant de dénigrer le propre
gouvernement le propre président de la
République et la propre ministre donc il
a été auditionné de cette association
cette association a apporté ses réponses
elle a dit que c'était une maladresse de
sa part qu'elle pensait ramener des
jeunes à l'intérêt du débat politique en
produisant de telles vidéos je vous
accorde et je suis complètement d'accord
avec vous que on peut tout à fait
questionner l'efficacité et la
pertinence de ces vidéos mais là aussi
pardon le dire mais c'est pas le
Watergate
merci madame la ministre pour ses
précisions maintenant nous allons passer
à la suite des questions avec Bertrand
sort
merci Madame présidente madame la
ministre merci pour votre franchise et
la clarté de ses réponses le baromètre
du mouvement associatif de 2022 montre
que le besoin de reconnaissance du rôle
citoyen et de l'utilité sociale de
l'association et la première
préoccupation exprimée par les
responsables associatifs la médaille de
la Jeunesse des Sports et de
l'engagement associatifs fait partie de
ses moyens de récompenser nos
concitoyens qui se sont distingués d'une
manière parfaitement honorable dans le
milieu associatif et dans des activités
associatives d'intérêt général partout
en France dans chacune de nos
circonscriptions nombreux sont les
bénévoles ou les dirigeants associatifs
à la mérité elle peut sembler pour
certains dépasser mais reste extrêmement
gratifiante pour son bénéficiaire fier
de voir des années d'engagement reconnus
et donne lieu dans chacune de nos
communes à des moments fédérants et à
des moments de liesse le mot est
peut-être un peu fort mais en tout cas
de joie partagée
toutefois les procédures de demande de
ces décorations et surtout d'attribution
sont administrativement trop lourdes et
trop longue les préfectures demandent
nombre de documents et le contingent des
médailles est beaucoup trop faible
beaucoup plus de bénévoles à mes yeux et
de dirigeants associatifs pleinement
investis pour leurs associations
devraient bénéficier de cette
reconnaissance aussi madame la ministre
je souhaiterais savoir si vous comptez
alléger voire réduire la lourdeur de ces
procédures et bien sûr élargir le quota
des médailles attribuées je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député Bruno
building
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre les associations sont en
maillon essentiel de notre cohésion
sociale vous n'ignorez pas que la crise
sanitaire et les mesures de
distanciation sociale ont largement
aggravé le phénomène déjà existant de
désengagement dans le Bel et vola et les
milieux associatifs si les associations
voient de manière générale leur activité
reprendre et vous l'avez évoqué madame
la ministre elle peine à trouver des
volontaires pour occuper les postes dans
leur bureau à tel point que l'on assiste
à l'arrêt d'association active faute de
pouvoir encore les gérer au-delà du
soutien financier et matériel le tissu
associatif a besoin de mettre en valeur
ce qui le font vivre de reconnaître leur
mérite et surtout de recruter de
nouvelles bonnes volontés pour occuper
des postes responsabilités dans les
associations ma question est donc la
suivante comment entendez-vous lutter
contre ce phénomène de désengagement et
comment proposez-vous de redynamiser le
tissu associatif je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député Fabienne Colboc merci
madame la Présidente merci Madame la
Ministre un mot tout d'abord pour vous
remercier pour votre travail sur la
simplification administrative tant
attendue depuis plusieurs années et sur
la valorisation de l'engagement citoyen
effectivement nous devons ton temps à
nos bénévoles et aux associations qui
œuvrent avec vitalité sur nos
territoires le fdva joue un rôle
essentiel ça a été dit en soutenant dans
les territoires les projets innovants
des petites et moyennes associations
notamment en ruralité et notamment aussi
sur la formation des bénévoles pour
l'année 2023 c'est un peu plus de 50
millions d'euros qui ont été mobilisés
madame la ministre financement vient en
partie des comptes bancaires inactifs et
des contrats d'assurance en déshérence
je pense qu'augmenter ce fléchage
pourrait être une belle opportunité pour
nous associations pour un montant
minimum et non un pourcentage ainsi
j'aimerais avoir votre avis et votre
volonté sur ce sujet car il n'est pas de
l'ordre législative je vous remercie
merci madame la députée Léo Walter
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre longtemps membre du bureau de
nombreuses associations je sais combien
la recherche de subventions et
chronophage est stressante pour ces
milliers de bénévoles qui font vivre ce
poumon essentiel de notre démocratie les
petites et moyennes associations que je
rencontre régulièrement dans ma
circonscription me font toutes parts de
la même difficulté lorsqu'elle dispose
d'un salarié ce qui n'est pas toujours
le cas loin sans faut la majeure partie
de son activité consiste à aller
chercher les moyens financiers pour
pérenniser son poste cette absurde et
cela interdit de se projeter sereinement
c'est pourquoi j'aurais voulu vous
interroger sur les mesures que vous
comptiez mettre en place pour sortir de
ce cercle vicieux mais depuis vous avez
semble-t-il largement simplifier les
procédures pour certaines subventions je
suis désolé d'y revenir mais les fiches
de projets des candidats retenus pour le
fond Marianne en ont donné une idée je
connais un certain nombre de
responsables associatifs qui aimeraient
bénéficier d'une telle simplification
mais je doute que cela soit possible le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que vos
réponses de tout à l'heure n'ont pas
levées se doute ma question sera donc la
suivante pensez-vous madame la ministre
avoir encore la crédibilité nécessaire
pour assumer vos fonctions je vous
remercie de votre écoute et de vos
réponses merci Emmanuel Antoine merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
les sciences sociales mettant en
évidence la perte d'indépendance du
mouvement associatif un article du
chercheur Thomas à chevalier récemment
publié dans la revue sociologique montre
une tentation d'instrumentalisation ou
de contrôle des associations par la
puissance publique les salariés des
associations voient leurs emplois
menacés si leur structure ne suit pas
l'agenda politique de leur financeur
public l'économiste Viviane tchernoog a
quant à elle montrait que le principe de
la subvention sollicité par une
association pour financer son projet
associatif s'efface au profit de celui
de la commande publique où les
associations répondent aux besoins de
l'action publique
l'affaire du Fonds Marianne illustre
cette tension sur l'autonomie des
associations et l'intervention du
politique dans leur domaine d'action du
fait de cette affaire cette audition
sera peut-être pour vous la dernière
devant le Parlement en tant que membre
du gouvernement mais ne pensez-vous pas
qu'ils soient plus que jamais nécessaire
d'apporter des garanties en faveur de
l'indépendance des associations
vis-à-vis de la sphère politique je vous
remercie merci madame la députée
Béatrice Piron
merci madame la présidente Madame la
miss ministre merci pour votre présence
ce soir en 2018 dans son rôle de soutien
développement de la vie associative le
Parlement a fait le choix d'abonder
historiquement à hauteur de 25 millions
d'euros le fdva se fera de ce fait connu
une extension de ses missions de soutien
à la vie associative car il soutient
désormais la formation des bénévoles au
sein des associations fdva un vue pas et
de l'ordre de leur fonctionnement ainsi
que leurs projets innovants fdva2 pour
un total d'environ 50 millions d'euros
néanmoins il convient de noter que les
seuils minimum de subventions diffèrent
selon les régions par exemple dans la
région Centre Val de Loire le montant
minimum alloué s'élève 1000 euros tandis
qu'en Île-de-France il est à 5000 euros
il est important à souligner que même au
sein d'une région par exemple
l'Île-de-France le département ne sont
pas tous d'accord concernant ce seuil
minimum par exemple les Yvelines
souhaiteraient réduire ce montant à 3000
euros tandis que Paris au contraire
souhaite l'augmenter à 10000 euros tout
cela aboutit donc à une situation de
statu quo dans cette optique je souhaite
connaître votre avis madame la ministre
sur ses seuil minimum de subvention qui
peuvent parfois écarter donc les petits
les petites associations enfin les choix
de thématiques à soutenir pourrait aussi
être décider en concertation avec les
élus locaux merci
merci madame la députée Philippe Balard
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre après le choc causé par
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty vous avez
souhaité lancer un fond en visant
financer les associations promouvant les
valeurs de la République pour lutter
contre le séparatisme et l'islam radical
depuis son assassinat en 2020 peu de
collectivités ont souhaité mener à bout
les projets de renommée des rues ou des
établissements à son nom cette semaine
encore à Paris par exemple la plaque en
son hommage a été dégradée et il s'agit
de la sixième fois rien depuis le mois
de février en avril dernier c'est
l'absence de volonté politique de la
part des élus et l'éducation nationale
qui avait fait échouer le changement de
nom du collège de Samuel Paty à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine madame la
ministre c'est une question réflexion en
quelque sorte que je vous soumets que
faire selon vous pour défendre sa
mémoire et soutenir les collectivités
qui sont encore trop frileuses à apposer
son nom sur des rues ou des
établissements je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député Estelle folest
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je vous remercie également de
votre présence et je voudrais moi vous
restituer le les discussions que j'ai pu
avoir donc retourner sur le terrain de
manière très pragmatique avec une
dizaine d'associations de ma
circonscription
parmi les sujets qui reviennent le plus
souvent il y a évidemment cette
recherche de subventions qui est
extrêmement chronophage très difficile
avec des niveaux états région
départements et peut-être même mécénats
qui sont qui se font dans des
temporalités différentes avec des bilans
d'action du coup qui sont extrêmement
difficiles à réaliser c'est une évidence
et puis il y a vraiment cette demande
très très forte d'un guichet unique
alors le contasso qui avait été cette
plateforme que vous avez mentionné tout
à l'heure et qui avait été créé en 2018
pour simplifier les démarches
administratives qui sont toujours trop
nombreux et trop lourdes semble encore
souffrir de deux mots majeurs soit les
associations le connaissent et elles ne
souhaitent pas l'utiliser parce que
c'est trop complexe et peut fonctionner
soit elle ne connaisse elle ne le
connaissent même pas donc j'aimerais
savoir puisque vous êtes autant que nous
attachés aux associations ce que vous
comptez faire très précisément pour
améliorer ce dispositif je vous remercie
merci madame la députée Stéphane Mazar
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre tout d'abord moi je tiens à
saluer l'augmentation du budget qui a
été alloué au fond de développement de
la vie associative dans un département
comme le mien c'est une augmentation de
21% de ce fond donc j'espère que la
trajectoire va être va être pérennisé
moi je vous a été dit sur la difficulté
pour les petites associations à monter
les dossiers fdva c'est assez complexe
et beaucoup d'Assos de petites
associations refusent ou renoncent ou
alors voir leur dossier rejeté pour pour
incomplétude c'est assez c'est assez
compliqué donc j'ai bien pris note de la
volonté de simplifier et d'assister ces
petites associations
ma question madame la ministre va porter
sur sur 2024 année des Jeux Olympiques
le sport grandes causes nationales
est-ce qu'il va y avoir pour les
associations qui portent le mouvement
sportif dans notre pays et qui sont en
première ligne pour porter l'héritage
d'après Jeux Olympiques est-ce qu'il va
y avoir un dispositif particulier pour
ces associations notamment au travers le
fdba merci Monsieur de député madame les
ministres je vous laisse répondre à
cette première salle de question
oui bien sûr merci madame la Présidente
je vais commencer dans l'ordre par
répondre à la question de Monsieur le
Député sort sur la question de la
médaille Jeunesse et Sport enfin moi je
partage complètement le constat que vous
avez dressé monsieur le député c'est
vrai que cette médaille elle est
extrêmement importante mais que le
contingent est extrêmement faible et
historiquement elle est jeunesse fort
vie associative et donc il y a un
contingent fort un contingent pardon
fort sur le sport traditionnellement ce
qui rend difficile tout le monde nous
fait le même retour que ce que vous nous
dites monsieur le député très difficile
le fait proposer des personnalités pour
la vie associative donc il reste soit
leur national du Mérite pour ceux qui
sont dirigeants associatifs et qui ont
des années de pratique derrière eux soit
c'est pour ça qu'on a créé ces médailles
du bénévolat qu'on a souhaité remettre
de manière plus souple et plus rapide
sur proposition notamment d'élus et je
remercie celles et ceux d'entre vous qui
nous ont proposé des personnes à décorer
je partage complètement ce que vous avez
dit la médaille ça fait pas en soi une
politique mais c'est un bel élément de
reconnaissance on parlait de
l'attractivité du bénévolat moi j'étais
très émue de décerner des médailles du
bénévolat des personnes qui ont ramené à
leurs enfants à leurs petits-enfants
cette médaille pour expliquer pourquoi
moi ils étaient engagés bénévolement
pourquoi parfois ira-t-elle repas
dominical en famille parce qu'ils
allaient s'engager pour une association
donc nous on va d'abord avec
l'administration soutenir la possibilité
d'augmenter le contingent et notamment
d'en faire une place importante pour la
vie associative d'une part et puis
d'autre part on a ce projet de médaille
du bénévolat qu'on a commencé à
distribuer qu'on va poursuivre et je
veux saluer madame la députée Fabienne
Colboc puisque c'est elle qui nous a
donné cette idée ce qu'on s'est inspiré
très directement de ce que Madame la
député a fait dans sa circonscription en
remettant des médailles qui m'avait
invité il y a 5 ans ou 6 ans de cela des
remises de médailles et on avait
considéré que c'était une bonne idée
qu'on la généralisé au niveau national
donc voilà je remercie madame la députée
à l'occasion
vous avez raison sur la question de la
baisse de l'engagement je veux dire que
le gouvernement tâche de développer une
culture de l'engagement notamment des
jeunes qui forment la France de demain
le service civique a été mentionné mais
aussi la plateforme je veux aider c'est
vraiment le sens de ce qu'on fait aussi
avec la VAE je redécaille pas j'en ai
beaucoup parlé dans mon propos liminaire
mais aussi du CEC du contrat
d'engagement républicain et c'est vrai
que quand on s'engage dans une coche je
pense que là encore la simplification
des démarches administratives va pouvoir
permettre d'apporter des réponses à cela
et en tout cas de redonner envie de
s'engager dans un certain nombre
d'associations et d'ailleurs le la fin
des Assises de la simplification et la
PPL qui sera portée à ce moment là je
pense peuvent être aussi un moment de
valorisation de l'engagement dans tout
le pays sous une forme qui reste à
définir mais qui nous permettra
justement de mettre en valeur et en
lumière par le biais de différents
événements et de et de le saluer madame
la députée Antoine vous savez on est
très modestes face à l'engagement moi
c'est ma 7e année de ministre mon
troisième ministère mon deuxième
quinquennat je crois que ça peut être le
dernier jour pour chacun d'entre nous
hélas tous les matins quand on se
réveille donc on entend très heureuse
d'être là avec vous de répondre à
l'invitation bah moi aussi du Parlement
et de pouvoir travailler avec vous et
avec les personnes avec lesquelles vous
travaillerez dans l'avenir mais je veux
dire en tout cas que je vous rejoins sur
la question du CPO je pense que c'est
vraiment un outil qui protège justement
les associations et qui fait en sorte
qu'elle soit pas soumise à tous les
écueils que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
et qui peuvent être des réalités je
parle de l'État mais ça peut être le cas
dans des collectivités et qu'elles
soient réelle ou pas en tout cas ça peut
être le ressenti d'association donc il
faut l'entendre donc je crois que
vraiment les CPO garantissent cette
liberté associative et évite que des
associations soient obligées de
re-remplir des documents et d'être
effectivement soumise à ce qui est fait
alors je distinguerai ceci étant quand
même les subventions de fonctionnement
de long terme les d'un projet et les
marchés publics qui sont des choses
différentes mais dans l'esprit je fais
évidemment évidemment pardon d'accord
avec vous et je pense que le CPE est une
belle protection pour cela madame la
député Piron sur la question du fdva
c'est vrai qu'on a un énorme enjeu pour
à la fois le pérenniser mais aussi le
faire connaître le montant du fond nous
ramène en dehors de grandeur similaire à
ce qui était la réserve parlementaire je
veux le redire la quote-part de 20% des
comptes inactifs depuis le PDF 2020 nous
a vraiment grandement aidé et on mène on
mène aussi des réflexions pour avoir un
plancher de fdva dans l'éventualité
Danny qui serait peut-être moins
fructueuse en matière de compte inactif
on sait jamais ce qui peut se produire
et les entreprises je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure mais je me permets de le redire
les entreprises de vos circonscriptions
peuvent alimenter le fdva c'est un bel
engagement de leur part pour celles qui
veulent justement faire acte de soutien
à la vie associative dans les
territoires n'hésitez pas à les
solliciter directement en tant que
parlementaire pour cela et sur la
méconnaissance du dispositif je veux
dire que la généralisation de guides
assaut elle devrait plutôt permettre
d'améliorer ce point les ingrédients
vraiment un réseau d'accompagnement qui
soit plus structuré et que les
associations qui sont en quête
d'informations puissent vraiment frapper
à la bonne porte monsieur le député
Philippe Ballard je n'ai hélas pas à moi
seul la réponse sur ce que vous évoquez
mais je vous remercie d'évoquer ce sujet
qui est important et qui nous tient à
cœur en tout cas qui me tient à cœur ici
moi je peux simplement vous dire
humblement à la place qui est la mienne
que je tâche de défendre tous les élus
courageux qui luttent pour la laïcité et
contre l'islamisme et qui s'engage je
mesure les risques que chacun prend et
j'ai eu à mesurer personnellement les
risques que cela en cours quand on
s'engage contre l'islamisme et donc j'en
suis tout à fait consciente et je veux
simplement dire qu'on soutient les élus
et l'ensemble des associations et des
associations et des structures qui
aujourd'hui prennent ces positions qui
sont je crois salutaire et écourageuses
Madame la député Foley sur la question
du compte à Sao notamment d'abord je
vous remercie pour votre participation
active aux Assises de la simplification
qui a été extrêmement
utile et efficace
sur le compte assault je veux dire qu'on
a là un outil que j'évoquais un peu dans
mon propos liminaire qui doit pouvoir
monter en puissance c'est vraiment une
demande de tous les acteurs associatifs
comme vous l'avez parfaitement décrit
ici le numéro et la plateforme numérique
ça ferait office de guichet unique qui
serait vraiment une manière aussi de
retracer l'ensemble des demandes et
désorganisations des associations ça
permettrait aussi d'éviter la saisie
multiple et répéter des dossiers mais
aussi de mieux informer les bénévoles
sur leurs droits sur les subventions
existantes sur les possibilités de
formation du CEC de la VAE et je le dis
parce que je suis très convaincu qu'il y
a encore aujourd'hui malgré le travail
qu'on a attaché de faire modestement
beaucoup de bénévoles qui ne savent pas
qu'ils peuvent transformer leur
expérience bénévole en diplôme grâce à
la VAE on va attacher de le faire encore
plus connaître
c'est moi qui vous remercie monsieur le
député Mazar sur la question des Jeux
Olympiques c'est vrai que c'est un sujet
extrêmement important pour nous d'abord
je veux dire à quel point nous avons à
la demande du Président de la République
avec la ministre des Sports réservé un
certain nombre de d'entrée de place aux
Jeux Olympiques pour des bénévoles ou
pour des membres d'association après
c'est vrai que il est important pour moi
de distinguer vraiment les rôles de
chacun et c'est vraiment le COJO qui est
à la manœuvre sur l'organisation et le
oui l'organisation et la ventilation des
bénévoles donc c'est important pour nous
de respecter cela mais également ce sera
un bon moment pour valoriser justement
cet engagement bénévole dans les clubs
sportifs au-delà de la question des Jeux
olympiques mais vraiment dans les petits
classes sportifs qui peuvent exister et
pour lesquels et bien il y a une
attention particulière à avoir et on est
pleinement mobilisé avec la ministre des
Sports pour faire en sorte justement que
les JO ne masquent pas l'activité des
petits clubs locaux sportifs mais au
contraire qu'elle puisse vraiment
les soutenir monsieur le député Walter
moi je partage ce que vous dites sur la
question des dossiers à remplir et c'est
pourquoi je crois qu'il est fondamental
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait un guichet
unique c'est ce que nous faisons avec
les assises de la simplification on aura
l'occasion dans l'hémicycle à la rentrée
d'en parler autour de la PPL sur la
simplification associative je l'espère
en tout cas et donc ce sera l'occasion
de mettre en place des process
extrêmement clairs qui pourront
d'ailleurs être nourris des retours
d'expérience de la commission
d'information du Sénat sur la manière
dont on doit aujourd'hui créer un
process d'attribution des subventions
pour toute la partie qui n'a pas de
règle écrit ou qui n'a pas de règle dans
la loi je crois que le guichet unique et
le numéro d'identification avec le dit
le nom une fois permettra à la fois plus
de transparence de retracer les demandes
des associations à travers le temps y
compris quand elles émargent auprès de
plusieurs ministères et de simplifier et
de clarifier les dispositifs de demandes
de subvention
merci Madame la Ministre donc je vais
prendre la suite des questions mais vous
nous mettez la pression quand même par
rapport à cette PPL qui de voilà mais je
j'entends donc Jérémy patrietus
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je souhaite à mon tour saluer
le rôle essentiel nos 16 millions de
bénévoles qui donnent de leur temps et
s'engage dans le million et demi
d'associations sportives culturelles
humanitaires sociales ou éducative dans
la circonscription rurale dont je suis
l'élu comme dans d'autres territoires
ruraux de notre pays les associations
jouent un rôle particulièrement majeur
contribuant aux liens social entre les
habitants et à la vitalité de nos
communes rurales elle participe de la
cohésion sociale et du lien
intergénérationnel malgré leur
contribution si précieuses à la vie de
nos communes rurales ces associations
manquent souvent de financement pour
organiser leur activité et remplir leur
mission c'est souvent un véritable
parcours du combattant pour trouver des
subventions là pour financer un concert
ici pour un tournoi sportif ou encore
une fête communale aux côtés des grandes
associations et des projets qui prennent
la lumière il est donc essentiel de
prendre en compte les plus petites nos
comités de faite nos foyers ruraux nos
clubs sportifs nos associations
patrimoniales et culturelles qui sont si
essentiels madame la ministre dans le
plan ambitieux France ruralité annoncé
il y a quelques jours par la première
ministre il n'y avait pas de mention de
nos associations rurales pouvez-vous
donc détailler les mesures qui
pourraient être prises par ailleurs pour
les soutenir je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député
Sarah le grain
merci madame la présidente madame la
secrétaire d'État chargée de la vie
associative Marlène Schiappa tout
d'abord je veux vous remercier d'être
enfin venu honoré de votre présence la
commission des affaires culturelles
Commission en charge de la vie
associative et à laquelle donc vous
devez des comptes certes vous avez mis
un an mais vous voilà et au vu des
récents événements et éventuels
remaniement j'imagine que c'est juste un
temps je vais vous poser une question
simple vous demandez aux associations de
signer un contrat d'engagement
républicain qui instaure une logique de
défiance culminant aujourd'hui dans une
vague de répression sans précédent du
mouvement associatif alors pouvez-vous
nous dire en quoi de votre côté vous
avez rempli votre contrat d'engagement
républicain comme je connais votre
pension pour les réponses évasives je
vais être plus précise pensez-vous qu'en
supprimant l'Observatoire de la laïcité
vous avez rempli votre contrat
d'engagement républicain pensez-vous
qu'en prenant au planning en vous en
prenant en planning familial vous avez
rempli votre contrat d'engagement
républicains et enfin surtout
pensez-vous qu'en détournant vers des
copinages et usages politiciens la
vocation du fond Marianne créa après
lassassinat de Samuel Paty vous avez
rempli un contrat d'engagement
républicain je vous remercie merci
madame la députée Francis Dubois
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je souhaiterais revenir sur la
visibilité les montants attribués par le
fdva les associations de terrain
dressent un constat inopérant et injuste
malgré la mise en place d'un dispositif
simplifié les petites associations n'y
trouvent pas leur compte elle ne
maîtrise pas suffisamment le dispositif
car il faut rappeler que ces petites
entités fonctionnent le plus souvent
avec des bénévoles pas toujours aguerris
au fonctionnement de l'administration un
déséquilibre important secret que les
grandes associations très rodées et
employant des salariés comment mieux
accompagner les petites associations
ou s'impliquent nombre de bénévoles et
dans le rôle est primordial pour assurer
du lien social et des événements au cœur
de nos campagnes se pose également la
question de la répartition des aides et
des montants au regard du nombre de
projets déposés en région nouvelle
Aquitaine seulement 30% des
sollicitations sont satisfaites ils sont
primordial de compléter ce dispositif
pourquoi pas envisager une réserve
parlementaire qui permettrait d'irriguer
au plus proche des petites associations
notamment en milieu rural je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le député Graziella
Melchior
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je vous remercie pour
l'ensemble des réponses que vous nous
avez apportées et je souhaitais
aujourd'hui vous faire part d'une
proposition bien que la plupart du temps
les présidentes et présidents
d'associations sages parfaitement gérer
les affaires courantes ils sont parfois
confrontés à des situations
conflictuelles que ce soit dans la
gestion de leurs équipes de bénévoles
salariés avec leurs membres ou les
participants et leurs animations dans ce
cas ils ne disposent pas forcément des
outils nécessaires n'ayant souvent pas
reçu de formation à l'instar de celles
proposées dans les entreprises pour la
gestion des conflits or des situations
préoccupantes peuvent constituer une
charge mentale et provoquer des
découragements dans la prise de
responsabilité et dans ce cas le
dirigeant n'a pas toujours le temps de
se former aussi je souhaitais savoir si
vous pensez pertinent d'imaginer de
nommer au sein des départements une ou
plusieurs personnes ressources
référentes bénévoles ou non qui
pourraient apporter des conseils à la
médiation et à la gestion des conflits
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
Laurent Croisier
merci madame la Présidente merci madame
la secrétaire d'État c'est dans le cadre
de la consultation nationale que vous
avez lancée et dont je salue
l'initiative que j'ai proposé les
ateliers aux associations de ma
circonscription dans le but de
recueillir leur remarque est proposition
de simplification les constats sont
partagés les démarches administratives
alourdissent le temps administratif
vient au détriment du temps associatif
et demande parfois des compétences
inaccessibles à des bénévoles des règles
identiques pour les petites ou les
grandes associations et le système
d'appel à projets de plus en plus
fréquent qui est insécurisent sur le
plan financier de ces constats les
associations formulées des demandes des
propositions moins de paperasses l'idée
d'un guichet unique pour unifier les
démarches et formulaires des
collectivités et des services de l'État
installé des référents associations dans
les maisons France services une
différenciation des exigences selon la
taille des associations et des contrats
d'engagement pluriel en lieu et place
des appels à projets
le tissu associatif et le bénévéla elle
bénévolat fonde l'exception française
être notre rôle d'élus est aussi de
simplifier la vie de nos associations et
je vous remercie pour la démarche que
vous avez lancée merci Monsieur député
Emmanuel Pellerin merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre je vous
remercie de votre présence aujourd'hui
du travail effectué pour la vie
associative un pilier essentiel de votre
démocratie et de notre cohésion sociale
en tant que député de
Boulogne-Billancourt je suis
régulièrement en contact avec des
associations de ma circonscription
véritable territoire territoire
associatif qui compte
2406 associations au total ces structure
par leur diversité et leur engagement
contribuent de manière significative à
la vitalité de notre territoire
elles sont le reflet de l'engagement
citoyen du partage et de la solidarité
qui anime nos concitoyens les
associations jouent également un rôle
essentiel dans l'insertion
professionnelle cependant j'ai pu
constater sur le terrain que certaines
associations peinent à recruter des
bénévoles par exemple la protection
civile qui effectue des maraudes chaque
semaine manque cruellement de bras aussi
je souhaitais madame la ministre savoir
comment le Gouvernement entend-il
promouvoir et valorisé le bénévolat
l'insertion et l'engagement citoyen au
sein des associations notamment auprès
des jeunes et des populations éloignées
de la vie associative merci infiniment
merci monsieur le député Laurent
esconégoce
merci Madame le présidente madame la
ministre le temps de l'engagement
associatif danse est désormais révolue
aujourd'hui l'heure est un engagement
plus ponctuel pour une cause un
événement pourtant les principes de
fonctionnement qui animent les
associations restent les mêmes répondre
aux appels à projets remplir les
demandes de subvention gérer les
plannings tout ces tâches rébarbatives
ont aujourd'hui atteint un sommet que
votre plan promet de réduire
significativement pour cela madame la
ministre et avant toute chose merci vous
avez su prendre accord un enjeu si
souvent présenté comme prioritaire par
les associations si je ne doute pas
qu'ensemble nous arriverons à simplifier
la vie des associations ces tâches
devront nécessairement continuer
d'exister il nous faudra alors mieux
répondre aux besoins de formation des
bénévoles également présentés comme un
enjeu clé par les associations madame la
ministre quelle piste présentez-vous
demain dans cette voie nous
parlementaires sont prêts à vous faire
des propositions j'associe à ma question
mon collègue Quentin bataillon je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le député Géraldine
Bannier
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre parmi les très nombreuses
associations que nous pourrions citer
l'association Lire et faire lire que je
connais bien via le groupe d'études
livres ma sollicité pour vous
transmettre plusieurs questions qui
rejoignent les préoccupations de très
nombreuses associations d'abord le sujet
de la disparité territoriale en termes
d'accès à la lecture c'est la question
du maillage territorial inégal des
bénévoles qui est posé nous est posée
également la question de la
simplification de l'accès subventions je
crois que vous y répondez en partie
grâce au guichet unique enfin nous est
posé la question de la formation des
bénévoles la formation d'animateurs en
accueil de loisirs autour du sujet
lecture est ainsi requise je vous
transmets ces demandes et une bonne idée
pour récompenser les bénévoles j'ai le
souvenir dans ma commune d'une
présidente de club de football la
première en Mayenne la première
présidente qui avait été récompensée en
ayant une entrée au Vendée Globe elle
était vraiment ravie donc je pense que
les territoires doivent s'engager pour
remettre ce genre de récompense à nos
bénévoles
merci madame la députée madame la
ministre vous avez la parole pour
répondre à ces différentes questions
de France ruralité alors c'est là qu'on
a été très heureux et je remercie à
madame la Première ministre d'avoir
arbitré favorablement dans le plan
France ruralité pour la création d'un
fond ruralité qui permet justement de
soutenir un certain nombre d'initiatives
issues des territoires ruraux je
rappelle que le FDA c'est donc 80% des
petites associations que guides d'assaut
accompagne vraiment à une maille fine et
dans ce fond ruralité on a 3 millions
d'euros de fonds d'amorçage pour les
organisations de l'économie sociale et
solidaire donc 80% des organisations de
l'ESSA sont des associations comme
j'imagine vous le savez et donc c'est un
engagement extrêmement important de
faire en sorte que ces structures
associatives soient vraiment soutenues
dans ce plan ruralité c'est aussi la
reconnaissance par madame la Première
ministre directement du rôle fondamental
des associations et plus largement
déstructures de l'économie sociale et
solidaire dans la ruralité puisque c'est
par nature une économie qui est non
localisable et donc qui mérite d'être
soutenu donc en tout cas je me réjouis
de cet arbitrage rendu par madame la
Première ministre monsieur le député
Dubois sur la question des petites
associations je partage complètement
l'analyse qui est la vôtre et également
de celle de madame la députée Melchior
sur la question des petites associations
et je vous remercie à Monsieur député
Dubois madame la difficulté Maker pour
votre soutien à ces petites associations
parce que c'est extrêmement important et
fondamentale de garder à l'esprit qu'on
a des grosses structures associatives
avec plusieurs centaines de personnes
mais qu'on a aussi tout de la même
manière des plus petites associations
donc c'est extrêmement extrêmement
important pour nous de pouvoir les
soutenir guides d'assaut sera une bonne
manière de les soutenir notamment pour
les situations préoccupantes parce que
c'est vrai à Madame la Députée la
rappeler il peut y avoir des situations
aussi litigieuses ou qui nécessitent de
la médiation au sein des associations et
donc je pense que c'est absolument
important et fondamental d'avoir en
appui de sortir d'une forme de solitude
quand on doit faire face à ces litige et
donc guides d'assaut sera vraiment un
guide quand ce sera déployé partout sur
le territoire très précieux sur sur ce
sujet
monsieur le député croisé je vous
remercie pour votre engagement sur la
question des Assises de la
simplification parce que c'est vrai
qu'on a eu beaucoup de parlementaires
qui se sont vraiment engagés et qui ont
permis d'avoir des remontées terrain
grâce à leur bonne connaissance du tissu
associatif dans leur circonscription et
souvent même au-delà donc merci vraiment
pour cet engagement parce que c'est ça
qui nous a permis d'avoir une fine des
propositions très concrètes et des
remontées vraiment extrêmement précises
et très pratique je pense alors je
n'aurais pas le temps de le développer
mais je pense notamment à la question de
la différence entre les tombolas et les
loto donc on a découvert que dans la loi
il n'était pas traitée de la même
manière dans le budget des associations
donc ça fait partie des simplification
qui peuvent paraître comme ça marginales
mais qui en fait je dis en regardant
monsieur le député Quentin bataillon qui
en fait vont être importante pour les
associations donc clarifié un certain
nombre de leurs situations et vont
permettre de lever des petits freins qui
étaient un peu ubuesque comme ça dans la
loi ou dans le règlement donc c'est
extrêmement important monsieur le député
pèlerin je vais d'abord saluer votre
engagement sur la question des maraudes
et auprès des associations de solidarité
puisque ça fait bien longtemps que vous
travaillez de concert avec le ministère
et que vous nous interpellez
régulièrement sur la situation des
bénévoles et des associations qui
pratiquent des maraudes dans les
Hauts-de-Seine aussi en Île-de-France et
partout sur le territoire donc je
saluais à cet engagement qui est
fondamental on est effectivement très
préoccupé par cette situation et je veux
aussi rappeler ici ici chacun le sait
mais peut-être s'il y avait des gens qui
nous regardaient c'est ton jamais à quel
point les maraudes sont essentiels aussi
l'été et que les associations les
grandes associations nationales
historiques et les associations locales
plus récentes qui font des maraudes
continuent à faire ces Maraux de l'été
ont toujours besoin de bénévoles d'aide
et de soutien donc c'est extrêmement
important pour nous dire que avec
l'hiver le besoin en maraude
ne s'arrête pas monsieur le député
espionner coxès je veux dire que je vous
remercie Cox pardon je prononce à
l'américaine ou à l'espagnol je ne sais
pas dans tous les cas à la française je
vous remercie pour vos propositions je
veux dire que c'est voilà d'abord merci
pour pour votre engagement à vos
propositions elles sont très utiles et
elles seront importantes pour nous dans
le cadre de ces travaux parce qu'on a
fait ses assises justement pour faire
les remontées des associations mais on a
aussi besoin que les élus puissent
continuer même à évoluer et à évaluer
avec nous les propositions qui ont été
remontées dans le cas de ces assises de
la simplification donc je vous dis merci
pour toutes ces propositions celles que
vous avez faites et celles je pense que
vous nous ferez encore ce que je
comprends qu'il y en a encore qui arrive
et que ça va être extrêmement important
pour nous de la même manière madame la
députée Bannier sur les bonnes pratiques
et sur l'engagement je pense que c'est
extrêmement fondamental qu'il est
important pour nous non seulement de
débusquer ce qui peut être négatif ou
difficile ou ubuesque ou qui peut
entraver peuvent être des freins pour
les associations mais qu'il est aussi
important pour nous de lever des bonnes
pratiques je pense que c'est extrêmement
fondamental et ces bonnes pratiques vous
permettez de les identifier et de les
dupliquer je mentionnais la question de
la médaille de madame la députée
Fabienne kolbock mais aussi des bonnes
pratiques d'association qu'on peut
mutualiser qu'on peut dupliquer ou des
bonnes pratiques de collectivité dans
leur lien avec les associations qu'on
peut écouter et qu'on peut soutenir
enfin Madame la Députée Sarah le grain
bah écoutez c'est avec grand plaisir que
je suis devant le Parlement le Parlement
contrôle l'action du Gouvernement donc
c'est bien évidemment naturel pour moi
de répondre à votre pardon
non mais je suis je suis en train de
vous répondre et d'ailleurs vous m'avez
interpellé quasi exclusif enfin
exclusivement d'ailleurs sur des choses
que j'ai menées dans mes précédentes
fonctions sur lesquels à l'époque vous
n'aviez pas interpellé donc je suis là
en tant que secrétaire d'État chargé de
la vie associative je vois pas rendre
compte de mon association de mon de mon
association non plus d'ailleurs mais ni
non plus de mon action en tant que
secrétaire d'état chargé l'égalité femme
homme ou mon accent d'adjointe au maire
ou de présidente d'associations il y a
15 ans je vais vous rendre compte de la
feuille de route pour la vie associative
moi j'entends ce que vous dites
maintenant pardon de le dire madame la
députée mais vos propos sont diffamants
vous parlez de détournement votre
copinage alors que l'ensemble des
acteurs qui ont travaillé sur la
question du dossier du fond Marianne
actes que il n'y a aucun copinage aucun
favoritisme c'est démontré c'est dit par
l'ensemble des acteurs qui ont été
auditionnés c'est même dit par les
présidents de la commission du Sénat
eux-mêmes pour copiner il faut avoir des
copains je n'ai aucun copain dans ce
dossier ça a été plus que démontré donc
je suis désolé de le dire mais vous-même
vous ne respectez pas les grands
principes républicains en diffamant une
ministre en faisant état de mensonges et
d'accusation qui aujourd'hui donc
aujourd'hui démontrer qu'elles sont
différentes et menthesongères donc je
tiens à être clair sur ce sujet je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre pour ses propos
et pour avoir répondu à toutes les
questions et je tiens à préciser que
lors de mon intervention je n'ai pas du
tout voulu cadrer ou limiter la parole
mais juste rappeler un certain nombre de
faits et notamment que les propos du
Sénat d'engageaient que les sénateurs et
que ici nous étions à l'Assemblée
nationale voilà donc Madame la Ministre
merci pour ces réponses j'ai bien
entendu que vous nous aviez mis la
pression sur la proposition de loi pour
la simplification de la vie associative
et pas que et que la différence entre
les lotos et les tombolas ce n'était pas
la même chose mais il y a un nombre de
paramètres encore à prendre en compte et
notamment c'est vrai que les
associations se plaignent souvent de la
multiplicité des dossiers et des papiers
qu'elle peut faire et c'est vrai que
vous avez évoqué votre précédent mandat
quand enfin votre précédente fonction
quand vous étiez secrétaire d'État à
l'égalité famome et nous avons eu
l'occasion de travailler ensemble
notamment
sur les associations et c'est vrai que
c'est une énorme demande quels sont et
notamment pour les contrats d'objectifs
donc encore merci pour toutes vos
réponses